what's your name that's such a name  where are you from uh Austin Austin okay  but where are you really from  just outside of Austin give it up for  Chardonnay everybody all right she's fun  [Music]  Almost Heaven  West Virginia  Blue Ridge Mountains it's not a gamble  if I know it's gonna work  [Music]  you're being a success is everything to  me  oh Jesus what's wrong with you your  parents are here they think I'm a  college in Houston  they don't know each other  it is  [Music]  you never know where you're gonna end up  only you know what you want what are the  other things set to 80 miles per hour  maybe we should set it's like 40 or  don't touch it  shame does you no good you deserve to  feel amazing  [Music]  [Applause]  you don't want the arm  s  [Music]  now and I promise you it's going to be  good  [Music]